did you ever text with 50 cent um we
sometimes i mean he's a little bit more
he's kind of in a tiff with stars about
what's going on with his shows really
yes because he um i don't really know
the logistics of it so he doesn't come
to set like he used to he used to come
all the time but right now you know he's
got his other stuff going on so we used
to talk more um but i mean he's so
supportive he's always so nice every
time he comes to set
um he's like make videos do whatever
like we have so much fun but yeah i wish
i wish the relationship was
like it used to be when i was power
season six because he was happy as a
clam he had four spin-offs with them
this and that
um yeah what is this it's power book the
first it was power yeah so i was on
power originally and then power book two
and then power both two is just a um
continuation of five and then there's
power book three power book three
raising kanan is a prequel of 50 cent's
character because he died it's a prequel
of
him growing up and then power book four
force yes that's um that's uh that's my
buddy tommy flanagan yeah i love tommy's
time he was just in the podcast was he
yeah he was great he i don't [ __ ] do
this with these rosie but i'm gonna do
it for you i love him so much he's so
fantastic you worked with him no but i'm
just huge sons of anarchy fans yeah he's
great um
so
yeah that's that's force so that's uh a
character that was originally in power
he escaped the feds and went to chicago
and that's his story there wow so how
many episodes of this have you done
since power and then power book i did
probably 35 at this point 35 yeah and
how many more
i mean they wanted to go for a long time
like how long did you sign on for seven
years i think but i mean they need to
get you they sign they can kill you off
at any time yeah but they sign you on
yeah forever yeah i mean that's a long
time but nowadays you're only doing what
eight to ten episodes a season yeah it's
ten episodes and you work like what four
months six months six months yeah six
because it's our drama in new york it's
not easy is it hard work it's hard work
are you exhausted by the end of the days
yes i'm exhausted middle day i'm like oh
[ __ ] am i gonna get because i'm also
like high comedy and this and that and
then some scenes i'll have this there's
a lot of um physical stuff you need to
do running fighting guns like whatever
crazy [ __ ] so
that's a lot of work but a lot like
since we're dealing drugs we'll shoot in
you know bad areas and in brooklyn and
queens night shoots all the time it's
freezing cold
it's hot it's always [ __ ] cold in new
york it's hard sorry for the f-bomb it
is my dad lives there and i'm like dad
it's either too freaking hot
or freezing for seven months a year
anybody who loves new york i like to
visit now every once in a while but i
can't live there and i used to live
there and i'm from new york so don't
badmouth me i'm a big fan of the mets
knicks rangers giants but i'm telling
you new york's always effing cold yeah
always and it used to be our schedule
used to be october to april but since
kovit it's now pushed to january to july
so you still get some warm months right
but yeah it's it is hard work sometimes
i'm like oh my god
join us every week as we discuss all
that is smallville we're gonna watch
every episode that's right with you
talkville the ultimate smallville
podcast we're gonna go way back join tom
welling and michael rosenbaum every week
as they rewind every episode of
smallville and discuss their experiences
with friends fans and co-stars talkville
the ultimate smallville podcast